MAX SALTONSTALL: Hi.
I'm Max Saltonstall,
and today I'm
going to walk you
through creating
your own private certificate
authority with Google Cloud's
new Certificate
Authority Service.
This new service can help
you simplify the deployment,
management, and
security of private CAs
without managing infrastructure.
Let's take a look.
From the console,
go to Security, then
Certificate Authority Service.
If you haven't yet,
enable the API now.
Create a new CA, choose Root
CA, and choose a region.
You can also see
below that we have
some premade recommended
configurations
to help you save time
with CA creation.
Next, configure the
new CA, filling out
the necessary fields.
The ID is the unique identifier
for this resource inside Google
Cloud and will be used
by other services.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now we need a key.
In this case, I've
already created one
using the Key Management
Service, which
I add at this step.
You can do it the same way, or
use a hardware security module
key.
As we update the Certificate
Authority Service,
we'll be adding the
ability to create
a key from inside this tool.
Now onto revocation,
for when we need
to tell clients to no longer
trust this certificate.
We use certificate revocation
lists to communicate this.
You can turn off
CRLs with this box.
Below, you can also decide to
enable authority certificate
publication that
enables chain validation
code on a recipient device to
navigate the full certificate
chain to the root.
Next, you can add a label
to enable easy grouping
of your cloud resources.
One final review to finalize
details before you create.
If it all looks good,
then let's run with it.
You'll now see the newly
created certificate authority
under the CA Manager tab.
Great.
We've got our certificate
authority setup.
Let's request a certificate
for my fictional
get snacks to joggers on
the go company, Eat and Run.
Choose the authority
you want to use,
and click Request Certificate.
Click on Provide CSR.
Then add your certificate
signing request
in the text box.
I'll use one I
made with OpenSSL.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You can see all certificates
issued by your CA
under Issued Certificates.
Click on the dots to download
any certificate for inspection
or use.
Congratulations!
You've created a
new CA and gotten
a new certificate in minutes--
much faster than the days or
weeks it would take to host it
yourself.
Check out the link
for more details
about Certificate Authority.
[MUSIC PLAYING]